Take a look at the concept map for Lesson Four that's laid out for
you right here. Again there are some blanks, for you to fill in as
we go throughout the lesson. I'd love for you to print this off. You
can find it in the instructor's notes here on this page. If you do need
the complete version now, because it helps you learn better, you can just skip
to the end of the lesson, download it from the instructor's notes. And then
use that. But for the rest of you, I really want you to print
this off with the blank and fill them in as we go through the lesson
as we get to that part and figure out what the answer is because at the
end of the lesson we'll have a chance
for you to assess your knowledge one more time.